Alex: Wooo we are live. Authors publishing ten books a week with a chatbot. Grandma googles and never leaves Google. An eight-minute site that sells zero. This is Episode Fifteen. We walk you to office 360 dot com.
Morgan: I'm Morgan. Amazon 2026 slop. Bill Johns, hundreds of titles, ten books a week at Amazon's cap. A vending machine in a cardigan. Real authors standing in a blizzard of paperbacks nobody asked for.
Alex: Zero click. AI Overviews. The sidewalk answers and your site is a party with no guests. The eight-minute website: pretty lobby, buy button to nowhere. The fix is a doorbell.
Morgan: The eight-minute site hallucinates calendars and example.com carts. If AI writes the sidewalk, your house must be findable when someone knocks. Book. Store. Done.
Alex: The Office 360. Four seniors. Lisbon to New York. You own the code. Three-click discoverability. office 360 dot com. STUDIO50. Half off. A house with keys, not a vending machine.
Morgan: You cannot out-slop the slop. Email theofficetechies@gmail.com: Story Time, Shout Out, Advertise, Donate. Then office 360 dot com.
Alex: Ten books a week should be in a museum. Real IA, real HTTPS, real forms, real ownership. office 360 dot com. STUDIO50. A true book with a doorbell outlives a blizzard of slop.
Morgan: Mailbox: Story Time, Shout Out, Advertise, Donate. Pretend you just left an AI overview. Three taps to the book. office 360 dot com.
Alex: Landing. Blizzard of paperbacks, sidewalk answers, eight-minute lobby. office 360 dot com. STUDIO50. Subscribe. Download. Tell an aunt. The doorbell works.
Morgan: Episode Fifteen. Ten books a week, zero clicks, eight-minute websites, doorbell at office 360 dot com. Email us. Listen. Download. Subscribe. Bye!